>>> FLORIDA GOVERNOR AND
POTENTIAL 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEE RON DeSANTIS IS FACING
BACKLASH BUT NOT JUST FROM
DEMOCRATS.
INSTEAD, FROM WITHIN HIS OWN
PARTY.
THIS COMES AFTER THE REPUBLICAN
CHARACTERIZED RUSSIA'S WAR IN
UKRAINE AS A TERRITORIAL DISPUTE
BETWEEN TWO COUNTRIES.
>> HERE TO DISCUSS, ALYSSA FAIR
GRIFFIN, CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE DIRECTOR, AND RON
BROWNSTEIN, SENIOR EDITOR AT THE
ATLANTIC.
WE'RE HEARING FROM MORE
REPUBLICANS WHO DISAGREE WITH I
WOULD SAY 2023 RON DeSANTIS
BECAUSE 2015 RON DeSANTIS SAID
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT.
LET'S LISTEN.
COURTESY OF THE K-FILE, A RADIO
INTERVIEW.
>> WE IN THE CONGRESS HAVE BEEN
URGING THE PRESIDENT, I HAVE
BEEN, TO PROVIDE ARMS TO
UKRAINE.
THEY WANT TO FIGHT THEIR GOOD
FIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT ASKING US TO FIGHT
IT FOR THEM.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
STEADFASTLY REFUSED.
AND I THINK THAT'S A MISTAKE.
>> SO THAT'S EIGHT YEARS AGO.
WHY THE FLIP?
>> I THINK THIS WAS A TERRIBLE
POLITICAL MISCALCULATION BY
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS BECAUSE IT WAS
PRECISELY THAT.
AS RECENTLY AS 2015 AFTER THE
INVASION OF CRIMEA, HE WAS IN
FAVOR OF ARMOR UKRAINE TO THE
TEETH AND CRITICIZING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOR NOT DOING
MORE.
THIS WAS CLEARLY AN EFFORT TO
CATER TO THE MAGA
ANTI-INTERVENTIONIST WING OF THE
GOP.
WHAT I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
SURPRISED TO LEARN IS THAT'S A
VAST MINORITY IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THE LANGUAGE I THINK REALLY
RESONATES IN A NEGATIVE WAY WITH
REPUBLICANS LIKE MYSELF IS TO
SAY THIS IS A TERRITORIAL
DISPUTE.
THAT LANGUAGE UNDERMINES AND
CALLS INTO QUESTION THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF UKRAINE, A
SOVEREIGN NATION INVADED BY
RUSSIA.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST
TIMES HE'S ACTUALLY GONE A BIT
TOO FAR EVEN WITH REGARD TO THE
MAINSTREAM OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND THEY'RE REALIZING THAT
NOW.
>> YET, THE TWO FRONT-RUNNERS
FOR REPUBLICAN NOMINEE, DONALD
TRUMP, HIS VIEWS AND COMMENTS ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE WAR
AREN'T THAT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM RON DeSANTIS.
IT'S ALL REASSURING TO HEAR FROM
REPUBLICANS NOW WHO ARE
DISAGREEING WITH THAT AND
SUPPORTING UKRAINE'S DEFENSE AND
THE UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE FOR THAT DEFENSE ITSELF.
BUT IF THEY BECOME THE NOMINEE,
WOULDN'T YOU IMAGINE ALL OF THAT
CHANGES?
HOW WOULD THEY RALLY AROUND A
CANDIDATE WHOSE VIEWS THEY
DIFFER ON FOREIGN POLICY LIKE
THIS?
>> THESE ARE THE TWO CANDIDATES
WHO IN POLLS WILL HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THREE-QUARTERS OF THE TOTAL
VOTE IN A REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
BOTH TAKING THIS POSITION THAT
IS AT ODDS WITH THE REALLY
POST-1952 DWIGHT EISENHOWER
BEATING ROBERT TRAFT REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I AGREE WITH MOST OF WHAT ALYSSA
SAID.
I DIFFER IN ONCE EXTENT.
I THINK THIS IS CLEARLY AN
EXAMPLE OF DONALD TRUMP BEING IN
RON DeSANTIS' HEAD.
AS I SAID TO YOU BEFORE, I THINK
THE CORE OF THE DeSANTIS
STRATEGY IS TO OFFER REPUBLICAN
VOTERS TRUMPISM WITHOUT TRUMP.
TO BASICALLY SAY I WILL BE AS
FIERCE A CULTURAL WARRIOR AS
TRUMP IS AGAINST ALL THE TARGETS
YOU WANT TO SMITE, BUT I DON'T
CARRY ALL THE PERSONAL BAGGAGE
OF TRUMP.
AND I THINK AS PART OF THAT HE
IS VERY DETERMINED NOT TO LET
TRUMP ESTABLISH A LOT OF
DAYLIGHT ON MANY OF THESE ISSUES
THAT HAVE ENORMOUS APPEAL TO THE
MAGA BASE OF THE PARTY.
THE RISK, OF COURSE, IS BY DOING
THAT, YOU'RE CREATING DISSIDENCE
BOTH WITH ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, AND EVEN MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY, IF YOU WIN THE
NOMINATION, I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
JOE BIDEN WOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
GOING INTO A GENERAL ELECTION
BASICALLY STANDING UP AS THE
DEFENDING OF THE WESTERN
ALLIANCE TO REBUFF VLADIMIR
PUTIN AGAINST AN OPPONENT WHO IS
CALLING THIS A TERRITORIAL
DISPUTE.
>> ALYSSA, BEFORE WE GET TO THE
NOMINATION, DO YOU THINK THIS
LANGUAGE, THIS POSITION FROM
DeSANTIS IS ENOUGH TO ALIENATE
SOME OF THOSE NEVER TRUMP OR
TRUMP RELUCTANT REPUBLICANS WHO
WERE LOOKING FOR A STRONG
ALTERNATIVE?
>> I THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH IN THE CONTEXT OF HISTORY
OF THE MOMENT THAT HE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO CLEAN IT UP.
A VOTER LIKE MYSELF, I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT SOMEONE WHO
WON'T SUPPORT CONTINUING AID TO
UKRAINE.
THE POINT DeSANTIS MAKES IS
CHINA IS THE BIGGEST U.S.
ADVERSARY RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T DISPUTE THAT, BUT HE
ARGUES WE CAN'T WALK AND CHEW
GUM, SUPPORT OUR UKRAINIAN
ALLIES WHILE COUNTERING CHINA.
I DISAGREE WITH THAT OUTRIGHT.
I THINK WE CAN DO BOTH OF THOSE
AND FRANKLY A VICTORIOUS PUTIN
IS A BOON TO CHINA.
I IMAGINE HE HAS TO CLARIFY THIS
AT SOME POINT, BEFORE IT GETS
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO A
NOMINATION.
>> RON, A TWO-PRONGED QUESTION.
HOW MANY REPUBLICANS AGREE WITH
ALYSSA'S VIEW HERE, AND IN
GENERAL, HISTORICALLY, WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A GENERAL
ELECTION, HOW MUCH OF A PRIORITY
IS FOREIGN POLICY, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S NOT THE UNITED STATES
DIRECTLY AT WAR?
>> SO FIRST QUESTION, GENERALLY
STILL A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
SAY THEY SUPPORT AID TO UKRAINE,
BUT THAT NUMBER IS STEADILY
DECLINING.
I'M GUESSING IF THERE ARE POLLS,
MORE RECENT POLLS THAN WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN EARLIER IN JANUARY OR
SO, WE MIGHT BE AT MAJORITY
OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING SUCH A CLEAR CUE FROM
THESE PARTY LEADER FIGURES.
IT'S A BIG DIVIDE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU HAVE SEEN THAT IN THE WAY IN
WHICH PEOPLE LIKE CHRIS CHRISTIE
HAVE EXPLICITLY COMPARED WHAT
DeSANTIS SAID TO APPEASEMENT, BY
NEVERAL CHAMBERLAND OF ADOLPH
HITBER BEFORE WORLD WAR II.
THAT'S EXPLOSIVE TO PUT INTO AN
INTRAPARTY DEBATE.
THIS ECHOES SEVEN DECADES AGO ON
WHETHER THE FOCUS SHOULD BE
DEFENDING EUROPE AGAINST RUSSIA
OR AN ASIA FIRST FOREIGN POLICY,
WHICH DeSANTIS IS KIND OF GOING
TOWARD AS WELL.
I DON'T THINK FOREIGN POLICY
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN THE
CENTRAL FULCRUM OF PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS EXCEPT WHEN WE'RE
ACTIVELY AT WAR, BUT IT GOES
INTO THE OVERALL EQUATION OF
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE, A, SOMEONE
IS UP TO THE JOB, AND B, WHAT IS
THE REAL FAULT LINE NOW, WHETHER
SOMEONE SHARES YOUR VALUES.
AND I LOOK AT DeSANTIS DOING
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF HIM ALSO
PUSHING LIKELY FOR A SIX-WEEK
ABORTION BAN, FOR PERMLESS GUN
CARRY IN FLORIDA, AND HE'S
TAKING A LOT OF STEPS -- HE
COULD BE A FORMIDABLE CANDIDATE
TO HELP REPUBLICANS REGAIN SOME